[Musique]
depuis un an que je sais que j'ai jamais
jamais
[Musique]
quinze des fléchissements c'est quoi les
escalera un pilleur parle aussi du quart
puis elle parle aussi de désarmer les
imputations binger par d'être un peu
aussi j'aime ce marché oui si j'ai mis
ça fait pas on n'a pas envie de mourir
en ont pu
récemment vient de la rivière moisie
[Musique]
pourquoi les gens font autant diable
parce qu'ils font rien
le visage du diabète à malioténam comme
dans la grande majorité des communautés
autochtones du québec
ils se rencontrent partout si on regarde
de façon globale ça c'est canadienne
chez les gens de 40 les autochtones des
quarantaines plus le taux de prévalence
est de environ quatre fois à cinq fois
plus élevé qu'un volcan canadienne c'est
une maladie qui dans progression le taux
de diabète atteint des sommets de 70 à
75% des gens de plus de 40 ans on the
bay dans sa peine communauté
stanley vollant et le premier chirurgien
autochtones au québec
il s'est fait connaître par un projet
fou une marche de 6000 km en territoire
doc tonnes pour promouvoir les saines
habitudes de vie
[Musique]
depuis 2008 la proportion d'adolescents
obèses dans la communauté a doublé à
chante de 14 à 28 %
or l'obésité est intimement liée au
développement du diabète de type 2 et
puis 00h01 et 00h44 même pas seul pour
le t2 le théâtre chose au total
dans le village de malioténam partout
des rampe pour handicapés
donc ces cinq opérations dans chaque rue
cinq opérations 28 puis jamais le cover
gevrey aurait depuis le début des années
90 le gouvernement fédéral conscient de
la catastrophe annoncée verse près de 45
millions $ par année depuis 2005 un
programme de prévention
à cela s'ajoute bon an mal an 65
millions $ en soins liés au diabète
je m'attendais pas à voir le diabète est
jeune mais j'ai les premiers temps je
surveillais beaucoup je faisais beaucoup
d'activités blanc depuis quelque temps
alors je vous dirais lâche comme je vais
je serai apte à laisser aller je te dire
des diagnostics à calage moi j'avais un
peu plus les 35 ans moi je sais pas
comment j'ai pu se passe des premiers
prix mais c'est pour cette raison que
je prends pas de médicaments aussi mais
des fois je les prends mes poches pas
très souvent pour un autochtone maladie
si ça signifie avoir marqué mais quand
on a pas mal nulle part c'est par la
maladie
je
les prochaines semaines c'est mon petit
péché mignon c'est pareil pour ma fille
je pense que ma grossesse
on est deux petites fenêtres vous avez
vous des petits même de toute une
banalisation par rapport au diabète tue
les gens qui se prennent soin d'eux
qu'ils vont faire d'exercice pour faire
attention ou pour manger les salaires
pour être vus comme des gens qui veulent
impressionner épater la galerie
tu m'aimeras les gens mangent trois
immenses n'importe quoi bah ça on était
des athlètes
j'ai juste et des athlètes là les
athlètes du canada mais les athlètes des
ginola c'était nous autres parce que
nous on était dix mois par année dans le
bois puis on est toutes un en marche
[Musique]
gouvernement ait voulu nous changer nous
sommes bien changé ça va prendre du
temps à mâcon rechange en redevient
dehimi quand on le fait
[Musique]